pour auch chamlou il est avocat franco
iranien bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors le 4e cycle des
discussions sur le nucléaire iranien
s'ouvre donc aujourd'hui entre les
représentants américains et iraniens
que peut-on attendre de ces négociations
bonjour merci pour votre implication du
combat l'attend secure en fait on se
rend compte que les deux parties veulent
conclure un accord aussi bien les
américains que les iraniens les iraniens
pourquoi parce que là si la situation
économique dans le grand est
catastrophique l'inflation est à peu
près de plus en plus de 40 % les prix
augmentent tous les jours et donc les
iraniens en faisant de cette époque pour
pouvoir reprendre les remettre en état
leurs économies les américains ont
besoin ils sont dans l'obligation de
signer cet apport aussi également
pourquoi ceci par la diplomatie des
américains ne réussissent pas s'il ya un
apport ou ne revienne pas dans cet
accord les iraniens dans un des dons
tout droit vers la bombe et ils ont des
capacités techniques et scientifiques
d'acquérir cette bombe et ses parents
savent autant quelques sites nucléaires
ou en assassinant et des scientifiques
que le programme sera pendant qu'on
empêchera les iraniens d'avoir la bombe
ont eu des retards doha ne les empêchera
pas d'avoir 7 7 alors justement à l'iran
a annoncé récemment avoir commencé à
enrichir l'uranium à hauteur de 60% et
pourtant deux hauts diplomates européens
évoquent la possibilité la possibilité
d'une heure d'une issue positif lors de
ces négociations aujourd'hui vous
partagez cet avis oui je partage cet
avis en fait l'iran a commencé à
enrichir l'uranium à 60% en réponse à
une explosion qui a eu lieu le 11 avril
sur sur leur site nucléaire de marcoule
et de latence et en réponse à ça ils ont
décidé d'augmenter d'augmenter de
l'enrichissement de l'uranium à 60% et
aussi également pour met de la pression
sur les états unis en disant que si vous
revenez pas d'accord nous allons
enrichir à 68 s'enfuir on va monter et à
part à 90 % et pour en fait et les
américains pour encourager les iraniens
assignée s'était pas ou à respecter
leurs engagements
davant 2018 hier soir le sécrétaire
d'état américain tony blinken a offert
aux iraniens en disant qu'on va
débloquer un milliard de dollars sur les
2 milliards d'avoirs iraniens je dis
bien d'avoir iranien n'est pas de
l'argent américain
les iraniens ont en avoir 2 2 milliards
de dollars aux etats unis cette somme
est bloqué tony gwynn canal a décidé de
de débloquer un milliard de dollars en
envoyant sur un compte suisse que l'iran
puisse utiliser juste dans le domaine
humanitaire pharmaceutique
agroalimentaire pour montrer leur bonne
foi et pour que les iraniens acceptent
de négocier et de signer un engagement
avec eux comment se positionne l'iran
dans ses négociations quelles sont les
attentes du pays concernant cet accord
deviennent 2015 on se rappelle que les
tensions étaient palpables un sou à
l'administration
trump puisque les états unis avaient
quitté l'accord et et l'iran elle fait
de même finalement est-ce qu'on a une
nouvelle approche là de la part de
l'iran
oui juste pour dire à guérande a agité
la toile
l'iran a commencé en fait à ne pas
respecter ses engagements d'avoir en
mais on est toujours dans la course et
la liste d'amis qui ont été d'abord là
quand la vente de l'iran est étonnant et
surtout la pente de la population
puisque une fois que l'accord a été
signé
vous avez eu moi en tant qu'avocat je
n'ai pas énormément de clients qui
venaient en iran qui se rendaient en
droit il y avait des délégations
d'entreprises françaises et européennes
internationales qui a dans les rangs
pour investir en iran l'économie était
en marche et est sur une bonne voie
et aujourd'hui la population iranienne
souhaite vraiment que l'accord soit
signé et évidemment pas un accord à
n'importe quel prix
l'iran ne va pas signer d'accord si ici
les missiles 26 au doigté propres et
dans la porte
l'iran ne veut pas de ça mais pour
d'économie du pays les iraniens veulent
ça mais il ya un petit problème c'est
qu'il y à bientôt dans un mois et demi
les élections présidentielles iraniennes
et on ne sait pas qui va être et d'une
puce de le président wade ne peut pas
surprise se représenter il a fait ses
deux mandats maintenant il y aura à
nouveau au président et on sait pas si
ce sera un conservateur ou un libéral
comme euros amis ou arrive mais ça
pourrait mettre en péril le maintien de
l'iran dans cet accord oui si si c'est
si c'est un conservateur
évidemment puisque les conservateurs ne
veut pas du tour de l'apport il avait
dit ça avant même la signature de la
porte mais même une fois que l'accord
avait été signé
il avait dit on peut pas compter sur les
états unis la parole de l'amérique n'est
pas à n'est pas faire et comme on a vu
des américains sont revenus sur des
rapports et les conservateurs ils
veulent ne veut pas de cet accord ils
veulent acquérir la bombe et ils veulent
avoir une puissance militaire nucléaire
puisque une économie saine pour la peau
le pays actuellement si je vous
comprends bien cet accord il est donnant
donnant et les favorable à tout le monde
si je puis dire il pourrait être en tout
cas favorable à tout le monde à l'iran
aux états unis avec israël à l'union
européenne
ça pourrait amener à tous mais mettre
tout le monde d'accord c'est je vous
comprends bien c'est sympa mais ça
pourrait mettre tout le monde d'accord
puisque comme je disais d'ici là si la
mairie ne signe pas cet accord l'iran va
aller vers la bombe est la seule façon
d'arrêter l'iran cesserait de déclencher
une guerre militaire le pour les
européens c'est un très bon accord aussi
parce que les entreprises européennes
veulent abaisser en moi ça a marché de
85 millions de personnes avec une
économie qui a besoin mais vraiment de
tout et tous produits venant de l'europe
il y en a besoin
c'est un accord un bien pour en iran
puisque l'économie va sortir de cette
situation catastrophique dans laquelle
aider et ça ça va savoir dès août à peu
près le problème pour tout le monde
kourosh chamoulaud merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat franco iranien merci
beaucoup